gioja el cambio climático parece ser el
único tema que acerca a china y eeuu
tras la visita de john kerry a shanghai
el resultado fue una declaración
conjunta sin precedentes en la que ambas
potencias las más contaminantes del
mundo se comprometen a trabajar hombro a
hombro por la implementación del acuerdo
de parís estados unidos y china
trabajarán juntos para abordar la crisis
climática creo que esta es la primera
vez que china firma una declaración para
decir que es una crisis ra esos este
acercamiento es lo contrario a lo que
ocurre en la arena política
la relación extensa eeuu sancionó a
funcionarios chinos por la presunta
violación de derechos humanos de la
minoría de los uigures
además hay guerras comerciales y está la
disputa por la autonomía de taiwán y
hong kong pero el presidente sí jinping
ya había dicho que el cambio climático
es una causa común que no debería ser
una moneda de cambio en la política una
posición que querer y respeta
no se trata de ideología esta no es una
gran competencia de poder se trata de
ciencia y de lo que la ciencia nos dice
que le estamos haciendo a nuestro inglés
va clara
pero y sigue tendiendo la diplomacia en
torno al medio ambiente con su viaje a
corea del sur el sábado la discusión fue
por cuenta de japón y su decisión de
descargar en el mar más de un millón de
toneladas de agua contaminada de su
dañada planta nuclear de fukushima
corea del sur quería una postura
vehemente de eeuu pero que me dijo que
tokio había tomado una decisión de
manera transparente
este es el abrebocas de lo que será una
cumbre convocada por bailén y que aspira
a reunir a 40 líderes mundiales de
manera virtual el 22 y el 23 de abril
con un único propósito unir esfuerzos
contra el cambio climático